[Music]
hello welcome to sofico visionaries me
sophie shepard nazi
when disaster strikes strong leadership
is needed to rebalance must
disorientation and regain control
who are our leaders and how do they
become them
well i asked one of the world's most
prolific thinkers on the psychology of
leadership
manfred katz de frise
manfred caste frias professor of
leadership development and
organizational changes at insead
business school it's really great to
have you with us
wow what uh amazing times to talk about
leaderships but i'm going to start
actually from a little behind so
we like to think of ideal leaders as
being modest
a little selfless accommodating
emotionally intelligent
compassionate instead etc you know so in
reality though
ask just about anyone about their boss
from hell
right and and the story goes that you
will hear plenty about
self-centeredness that they're rough
they're insensitive as leaders
uh is it realistic to think that this
gap between the
ideal and the real the realistic
can be actually bridged i hope so
otherwise what why would i do what i do
i do something else in my life
i mean you're right you know you all
need a degree of narcissism
life but unfortunately too many leaders
are looking really out for number one
and not for the common good
it's uh it's very true and the nice term
to use about humility
sense of humanity empathy all those
things you wonder they went
down by the wayside so that's so there
is
in that respect we live actually very
interesting times because of the
pandemic because it focuses
in a way it's the largest social
experiment ever done
you know it could have a number of
scenarios you condition one is that
people become more reflective and say
what kind of world do we need
i mean at the moment uh you know i look
at the world
and i remember many years ago before you
were born i read this book about silent
spring which talked about
how you're poisoning the earth so now
people are more concerned of course
about
global warming and things like that
there was also a movie which
was in the 60s which was of course in
the time of the cold war
that was dr strangelove you probably
never saw it it's an ironic movie about
the danger of nuclear uh
holocaust and so that's still there
actually when you think about countries
like
pakistan and north korea you don't get a
warm feeling what's uh
having the finger on the nuclear button
then of course you have
the terrorism which is all over the
place which is still there
and then you have what's uh you know
also in russia the case i know asia
quite well because there's
been so many times there is income in
inequalities i mean
you look at america and it's enormous
fortunately europe where i live it's
much less
and of course countries like poland and
sweden it's much
more equal but when you have large
incoming inequalities it's an
invitation for social disaster and
and then you have the pandemic and the
way different countries have dealt with
the pandemic bad examples of course
being countries like america
uh brazil and also a country like
india you know a terrible way of dealing
with it
which you know that masculinity is
supposed to be
people who don't don't wear masks are
you know real man
quote unquote and totally ridiculous
anyhow it's uh it's really a perfect
storm
and uh and well of course what we need
our leaders sophia
you mentioned uh you know who are
compassionate
and have some empathy instead of we have
there has been a rise of populism so
people uh
pick leaders who cater to our
wish to believe snake oil salesman you
know which is totally unrealistic
but but let's be a little more precise
because what i would like to talk to you
during this interview about leadership
and different kinds of walks of lives
but now we've touched upon
the world leaders right the political
leaders and you're saying this is the
perfect storm
and this perfect storm actually brings
to surface
all the downfalls of the systems of the
people who are
actually heading the countries masks are
off i mean never has there been a time
where
everything has been so clear when they
say the king is naked this is the time
about the saying so it seems like
looking over
uh the the world landscape a political
leadership landscape
you're very probably you say the kings
because queens do better
we're gonna that's my next question
that's my next question but if we talk
about the kings that are naked
right uh and that has become obvious
during the pandemic um
it it has a lot of people thinking that
maybe
the the political elite that is heading
the world right now
lives in a old paradigm that doesn't
correspond
the new problems that the world is
facing and i'm not really only talking
about
the pandemic the pandemic will go away
in a year and a half
hopefully right there will be a vaccine
i mean every hundred years there is a
pandemic
but i'm talking about the problems that
it has brought to surface
and the inability of the current
political
elite to deal with these new problems
that just don't correspond that old
political paradigm
what kind of leaders do we need
right now considering that we know more
precisely what are the problems the
world is facing now
now you know certain things are not new
and i think one of the
the important and the the problem
we always have is the great factor you
know the element of uh
great has been there throughout the ages
and that's still there and
and and that's i think and fairly
you know so silent motivator that people
behave the way they do
i mean it's when you take the united
states as an example
even in the you know if even the richest
communities
where the most birthday they have the
best education because obviously
education is a way of
looking through uh the wish to believe
to people who
promise miracles they still will
vote for trump many of them vote for
trump because of
uh it is advantageous to them
financially which is a very short
short way or a short way of looking at
it and it's very it's very sad to hear
that this
you know short term i mean so the
you end up in a country which is divided
and people
live in safe communities guarded by
whatever
towers protects and goons who protect
them
which is a terrible way of living i
think so
the greed factor has always been there
and it is uh unfortunately uh
has come very much to the fore coming
back to your question and you already
answered your question yourself
and what you need is people who are
courageous
and are willing to face reality as one
of the problems by the way that we live
now in an age of
uh the social media has an enormous
effect
and you know the and russia is no
stranger to that by the way in the
distribution of factoids and
but the whole world has become mastery
in that and it is
quite unfortunate that you start to get
confused what is real and what's not
here
a lot of people that i've spoken to said
you know when
things like pandemics happen right where
when there's so much uncertainty and no
one has the answers
you can be the most experienced leader
and you can be very smart and you can be
very talented
but unless you have emotional
intelligence
and that encompasses a lot of other
traits within itself
for instance empathy and adaptivity
there's no way you can lead a nation
out of crisis like pandemic would you
agree with this would you agree that
something like emotional intelligence is
a must-have
for a good leader during the times of
crisis like this
the first thing you have to know what
are your strengths and weaknesses you
can do it all
leadership is really a team sport and
unfortunately trump
to give that example because i like the
example since i'm also
know i'm a psychoanalyst in my other
life of two heads from a management
professor and psychoanalyst
he is the example of what's called a
malignant narcissist
and a malignant narcissist is basically
i've written quite a bit about him
actually because i got so
yeah i can believe it that people pick a
sickle
which he really is as so he basically
his
major themes is he is so insecure that's
all about him
it would never be about it's always
about himself about him and the second
thing is faith vindictive
so anybody who's not with him is against
him and he will do anything to crush the
person he has to win
which is going to be interesting because
of this election because he
cannot lose in his mind so he has to
find all different ways to find excuses
not to lose
so that's uh but coming back to
executives you know the first thing
i try to do in my coming back to your
question about emotional intelligence
is the question of know thyself and to
understand their strengths and
weaknesses
so many executives don't know themselves
they don't know why they're doing what
they're doing
the second thing is that they often and
russia is a very good example actually
given the power distance in russia which
is kind of remarkable different
you think about communism and things
like that in the past
but there is enormous amount of
obedience to authority
so this great tendency for another greek
word called eubrees people become too
full of themselves
and nobody can push them back which is
the case of course also on trump
and the so that and and that is also the
road to self-destruction so it's always
my surprise that
people many people have a tendency to
self-destruct in a leadership position
unless you have
a greater corporate culture where people
have a healthy disrespect for their boss
but it's not so easy
and particularly last year i don't
credit some work there with
organizations and
again the power distance the second
thing that always surprises me or the
searching
that many executives don't get the best
out of their people
it's really again they have no again has
to do with emotional intelligence and
what i found very noticeable after the
first week in my program which is four
weeks over a year
the first thing they do they don't know
their people they never had a serious
conversation with them
they have never listened to them so
that's what they do
they start to have some conversation
with them the other thing has to do with
teams as i said leadership is a team
sport
and since you can do everything you
should focus on the things you're good
at
and you should find people who can
compensate for the things you're not
good at
and so i always say give me a somewhat
neurotic team and i make something out
of it in a short time i'm just be
in my work at insead i've been quite a
pioneer in team coaching so to really
and it always surprises me when you look
at exactly at
leadership in organizations that people
spend millions
tens of millions of dollars or whatever
euros whatever
on i.t systems things like that but they
are unable to align the top team
and that costs more money because you
get turf fights bearings all the scans
things people are not aligned
manfred we're going to take a short
break right now when we're back we'll
continue talking to
manfred katz is one of the most prolific
thinkers on the psychology of leadership
talking about
what kind of leaders does the world need
today stay with us
[Music]
and we're back with manfred katz dufre a
prolific thinker on the psychology of
leadership manfred correct me if i wrong
but what i see in real life
is that vast majority of leaders whether
it's ceos of corporations whether it's
heads of states whether it's you know
just uh
heads of little small companies doesn't
matter
they have the trades that good guys
don't have
you know because good guys always finish
last i mean you talk about trump being
a malignant narcissist but a lot of
people who actually get to power
are of power hungry are narcissistic are
pushy
they do like sort of go over other
people's heads to get what they want
and that's why their leaders and other
good guys with compassion
and emotional intelligence always stay
behind
i wrote this in the article about we
should have leaders for life
and uh you know which was a very cynical
article because leaders for life
are not it doesn't make make for
stability in the country
and also not good for any organization
so
in the short run those people might
come up but i think one should do
everything
to have some checks and balances to
prevent those people to come to the fore
that's the reason for example
i've developed many kinds of 360
questionnaires
that you basically tease out the
narcissist i mean the
pathological message narcissist is part
of the deal by the way
but it's the question of access always
you need to be narcissistic it was made
for self-confidence
but the excess that people can push back
they can
people can tell a person you're full of
you know that kind of thing
you know stop it this doesn't go
anywhere but i think when you have too
much obedience to authority people are
reluctant
and many of the leaders you talk about
live in the echo chamber
i mean they know what they think they
want why won't are they interesting what
other people think
that's i think important that's the way
you learn you don't learn by just
telling yourself the same thing
so this day and age you can have some
autocrats who take advantage of the
pandemic
you can also say maybe we should have
somewhat of a different world and you
have to be somewhat without hope
and that's partially also the younger
generation i mean
i i'm not going to when you think about
global warming i'm too old
to really oh come on you're not too old
yeah i don't feel at all but i mean i
mean i'm not going to necessarily affect
be affected so much by that but when you
think about my children and
grandchildren they are and so you i can
see
that you know that the younger
generation
maybe the pandemic is
is actually the revenge of the younger
generation because the younger
generation was so affected my age is
more the one who
gets affected by it maybe that's what it
is to finally get all those people out
of the way
who uh have certain ways of looking at
things but let's say you leave
a couple of centuries ago right and you
tutor i don't know let's say prince of
orange and he hasn't
let the revolts yet yeah um what are you
gonna teach him what are the essential
leadership qualities you will try to
grow in him
now i guess one thing we talk about
certain qualities one is to have certain
amounts of self-confidence
i had one executive who was runs a large
media company
who told me thank you thank you for
being in the seminar
because i had the courage that she
doesn't have before he was a very
insecure person
to make some tough decisions one thing
is i'm not going to fire anybody
that was actually a very tough decision
because it was much easier to invent
panic you fight with
i said he said i'm not going to fire
anybody i'm going to really help the
hospitals also i have
i i i take a salary cut with the whole
top executive team
and say later at zeta so courage to have
courage to do certain things
and and to stand up and say this is
right
and it's you know everybody who is
created is also fearful
but you can there is such thing as a
courage muscle to say this
this cannot stand yeah so you have
self-confidence to
i mean when you look at the trump person
he's basically a child who never grew up
he's so insecure he needs all the time
reinforcement
so to be to be more aware of what you
can do and can do coming back to
strengths and weaknesses
it also coming back to your comments
about care that you have a sense of
compassion
now you have to do it in this in
moderation because if you're too
too empathic you don't act anymore
everything is you can relation you can
understand everything but you might be
paralyzed what about cold-bloodedness
is this something a good leader should
also balance in himself
now that has to do with the balance of
uh compassion
and uh you imagine i mean
i'll explain what i mean because when
you see
big leaders they need to take big
decisions
and even though it's for the good of the
people in the long run
it doesn't necessarily come across that
way to the people right then and there
and people sometimes have to suffer for
big reforms for a certain period of time
five years ten years that's a big chunk
of time for one person's life
so these people are faced with the fact
be compassionate not go with the reforms
and you know let the people be happy now
or
be cold-blooded go on with the reform
whether it's a big ceo of a company or
president of a country
but in the long run even though people
aren't happy now with the reforms
it will be better off for the country or
for the company
now i see it not as cold bloodedness
it as her being courageous sometimes you
know you have to make difficult decision
because they're the right decision as as
far as you can see and that's the reason
supposedly you are elected but when you
elect people who are just
catered to the wish to believe like you
see in brazil
this i mean this uh this kind of this
kind of person or i mean
coming back to america they don't have
that competence to make those decisions
now if they
if they really realize they are stupid
they would
they are but stupid people don't realize
that they would surround themselves with
people who can give
good advice i mean look at apocalypse
like coming back to america which is
such a good example
of robert reagan he was an actor and uh
but he also knew vernee was out of his
depth so he made
you know he he had petty decent advices
that's not the case when you look at the
present situation in america
so cold-bloodedness is the best the
ability i think to take some distance
and be able to explain what you think is
the
in in the better interest in the nation
and there was a man called adenhower who
was the
german uh you know the german counselor
he said uh a thick skin is a gift of god
unfortunately at as a leader at times
you have need to have a sick skin
because
you can never please everybody if you
want to please everybody you sell ice
cream
that's my advice is there like a natural
divide in people between leaders and
followers and some people are destined
to lead and others follow or
anyone really can grow a leader in
himself if he wants to
that's a very interesting question and
not easy to answer because
some people feel much better i mean in
cases of crisis
we have a tendency to go back to what's
called the independency assumption
be looking for someone who can lead us
you know there's it's probably it's
already from paleolithic
times you know we talk about our
evolution we look for somebody
that's in general tendency we also have
this fight flight response at the same
time
and and some people depending on the
background i mean i mean as a
psychoanalyst you look at some
developmental
you know it was actually freud who used
to say uh
talked about minor gold in the city if
you are as a man this is a male leader
if if if you have been the favorite of
your mother you can't lose that's what
he said
so you you get a lot of self con you
have this female for conqueror you can
do anything
and actually you can have similar you
look at margaret thatcher at the time
she or she it was interesting when you
read the autobiography
there is no mother there there's only a
father which was interesting because
in in the in this male chauvinistic
world
she lived in her father want to have a
son so the
daughter was brought up as a tomboy so
you have different
but of course the best scenario i think
is that it's not just honey i'm home you
know the kind of man coming home
but you have two honeys coming home so
you have the role models in the family
and those make it different if you have
a very confident as a woman if you have
a very competent mother
it really sets up a role model it really
depends how
what kind of relationships are developed
in the family
it's a little bit like also uh you know
coming back to security do you know the
parable of the hedgehog
no that's of schopenhauer imagine you're
a hedgehog it's cold in the winter
and you want to get warmer so some other
headshots and you try to get closer
but as a hedgehog how close can you get
before you
bad things happen to you this thing so
you have different kinds of headshots
you have to find the proper distance
so according when you come back to child
development
there are three strategies usually one
is secure attachment
that you feel comfortable a certain
distance some people don't want to get
close they are always avoidant because
everything ends badly
and then you have the people are very
needy so coming back to your question
if you have people who are very needy
probably they're better followers
you know anxious attachment they want
they look for someone it's always
interesting to me because
this hedgehog metaphor sets the stage of
couple relationships and the
relationships you have in organizations
so so if you are for example very
avoidant
and your partner is very needy it's bad
news
you know you one partner is running
after you the other one wants to take
this
yeah coming back to uh your question
about leadership
certainly given on your particular the
attachment behavior you have very early
in life
which has to do with what kind of care
you had
some people will be much better
followers other people who are more
secure in their skin
might be much better leaders do you
think
the demands of what a good leader or
traits of a good leader
should be change according to the times
we live in
or a good leader is a good leader
anywhere anytime
now that i mean of course the different
things we have now we live in the
information society
you need certain different skills but i
mean i wrote once
not skills traits no i mean coming back
to the quest it's a question which i've
been asked before
and i was i was and some journalists
asked me that before and he said you
know
the leadership skills of alexander the
great genghis khan
and uh zulu
uh you know some phase similarly you
need now
now to i thought it was a flippant
remark to a journalist
so in the end i wrote a book on
alexander the great i wrote the book on
shaq as which was the
it was the leader of southern f southern
africa
never genghis khan i had a problem with
that because of there is not much
written about changes kind but not in
written society but i think many of the
qualities are still the same which has
to do
uh you know when you look at uh
alexander the great
you know the use of symbolism in his
particular uh
way of operating was very good in that
also
the way before the battle you know he
would be informed by the way which is
stupid if you are the leader of
the troops because you can be killed and
you will see certainly it was no
stranger to many wounds
also before the battle talking to people
singling people out and things like that
the people felt special
so that's i mean to really you know
really
create a community of people and that's
still the case like you have
uh henry v the famous bottle of
agincourt there's the famous speech
there
and he and he singles out all his major
people
so they felt really committed they will
fight till the end
they will do anything if there's someone
that you think is a great model of a
great leader
that corresponds to today's reality in
today's times
who would it be can you name a president
or a
ceo of a company that you think fits
perfectly
the times and challenges of today i felt
that
mrs merkel has done a pretty good job
i think she has done a pretty good job
it's not an easy country to manage
and she has been she made some mistakes
which
uh you know underestimating for example
the influx of immigrants
and the impact it had on society but she
has been
pretty decent pretty has a woman of
strong values
i think when you look at some other
women uh i mean
uh you know so let's look at some of the
scandinavian countries
man i am i am i'm a more
more reluctant at the moment so on that
optimistic
note that it's the era of the woman
leaders uh
that is actually coming um i would like
to thank you manfred it's been really
a treat talking to you and i hope we get
to do this again and maybe i can
actually
connect with you when i'm in paris and
we can talk more about this because
this is a really interesting topic that
has come
more than ever in focus right now so
thanks a lot for your tips and for your
thoughts and insights thank you thank
you for having me
thank you
[Music]
you